hey everybody
welcome to our kitchen i am your girl
candy
with my daughter riley aka riles
why she got to be all extra aka ryan
it's my slogan that's what you do when
you're about to cook you gotta give
yourself back when you're the queen of
the kitchen you gotta do the whole thing
i don't know if she earned that title
yet i did but
she can cook a little bit
you know with the world just being so
crazy everybody has been
cooking this whole last few months
that i pulled out every new recipe that
i can find
you about to leave yourself to go to
school if you're like me
students who are going back this year
and don't know what to expect
you can feel a little bit normal cook a
little bit either with people in your
dorm your family at home if you're
doing online schooling i have a good
recipe for you riley and what did you
pick for us
snickerdoodle bread pudding
it'll be the first time i ever tried to
actually make it okay don't be trying to
outshine me today
i don't really have to try
[Music]
i love the fact i can get everything
from one store
kroger when we first went into
quarantine
there were a lot of people who did not
know where their next check
comes from and i bought tons of gift
cards from kroger
because i knew that kroger would have
exactly what they needed
in a medium bowl mix together egg milk
vanilla cinnamon sugar salt and raisin
and i don't know if i trust her to crack
eggs
we having fun in the kitchen it's okay
you need to cut the fingernails down
i don't think they're that long thank
you
how about you do this part we can take
turns turn it so you can see the half
cufflink
i can see the half cup line on this side
okay half a cup
perfection
of course you had to do a little singing
that's what i like to do what i cook you
know
always singing listen i feel like when
you got some good food you gotta sing
honey
you gotta do a little song a little
dance you know it makes you feel good
a vanilla extract kroger brand i use it
all the time
for a lot of my different recipes
especially
see see once again those fingernails
i don't know how you do anything with
those
cinnamon by kroger i feel like vanna
white
do you even know who vanna white is no i
think that's your generation
when you have a dessert what you need
first
sugar make sure that spoon is filled
i like my stuff sweet i say
add a little bit more sugar girl why you
weren't doing too much
sugar ain't never hurting nobody she
doesn't
go by her own recipes i do i just add a
little
love 1 8 teaspoon of salt
okay all right
see my nails could probably do that bam
now this is what you do not overdo with
the salt it's only to enhance the flavor
raisins are
optional i'm not a raisin girl bread
pudding has to have raisins
go light it says two tablespoons
so i'll do a teaspoon oh and then a
couple for good luck oh god
that didn't seem like you went light but
okay my only
suggestion is to branch out of soul food
and try a lot of different things
i branch out when i go out to eat
three slices of kroger's market and meal
bakery bread this is one of my favorite
breads i truly love this bread to make
french toast with
so i'm hoping that it tastes just as
good for the bread pudding
can you get my knife sushi how did i
become the sous chef
you are my assistant always thank you
slice into one inch pieces
look at you dropping my bread to the
flat
i'm okay i got it you gotta fold the
bread in there
i don't see any folding going on this is
folding
let me see you fold something let me see
oh sorry
i was a single mom when i first had
riley you know our connection is always
going to be a little bit different
um sometimes i feel like she's more like
a
sister or homegirl especially as she's
getting older
we have a lot in common and we think
alike
yeah sugar microwave for three minutes
and when done let's sit in the microwave
for one minute
okay well while we're waiting on that
slice some strawberries to like garnish
make it look pretty see i guess we make
a pretty good team we do
i love learning from you in the kitchen
you guys at home make sure you learn
from your parents how to cook
or learn from anyone if you know any
good cooks around you make sure you
learn before you leave the house
because now i feel like i'm very well
prepared i can't believe this is your
last
week before you leave to go to college
yeah i'm going to miss you this is kind
of like a moment
oh when you have family
wait why did your head like you didn't
want me to hug you or something see this
is how your teenagers do you
all right come on that's the longest
three minutes i've ever seen in my life
10 seconds
it smells good and you haven't even
taken it out the microwave yet
now this one's going to be yours because
we got it most of the raisins are in
this one
look don't get mad at me because i got
an atlanta accent
garnish it with strawberries you know
what
i think i want to get just a little bit
more sugar
more we are we already put more than the
recommended amount
we just sprayed though okay so another
garnish on top of the
garnish oh that is way too much
are you afraid of sugar or something
come on
let's try it taste test
[Music]
snickerdoodle easy
quick and good you could even have it
for breakfast
yeah it kind of tastes kind of like my
french toast but but better
better than my french toast if you're
like me going to school
you can go cook with your dorm mates and
have fun all you need is the microwave
mm-hmm go to kroger get the ingredients
and cook it on up for your family and
thanks for cooking with riles and candy
and hopefully we see you again did you
just throw me on the back
[Music]
i mean let's be honest i didn't watch
the work so i'm gonna eat my bread food
[Music]